je suis vraiment désolé casimir mais je
retrouve pas cette botte d'oignons je
suis sûr que j'en avais pourtant tu peux
vraiment pas temps forts mais non un
sandwich à la confiture de prunes et au
camembert sans oignons mais c'est comme
un jour sans pain ou un gloubi boulga
sont si ce que tu ne retrouve pas les
oignons
jean-françois bonjour je dis oui excusez
moi facteurs le salut casimir il ya plus
de nyon
mais non c'est qu'ils naître ce n'est
pas qu'il n'y ait plus d'oignons mais si
je ne sais plus je les ennemis cela dit
monsieur campagne s'en moquent
éperdument sommes pas du tout pas du
tout donc je n'ai justement vous demandé
un sandwich au pâté de foie avec de
l'oignon pas parce que moi aussi j'ai un
petit code ça va alors c'est bien ma
veine vous mangez les oignons centre
confiture de prunes vous mais de
préférence oui c'est dégoûtant
vous avez vraiment des goûts bizarres
chacun son opinion casimir moi je ne
discute pas tes goûts mais je puis
affirmer que je passe pour un des plus
fins gastronomes de lille
je crois même que j'en suis le plus
grand mangeur vous le plus grand mangeur
de lille tu peux rire voici tu crois que
tu es pas de quelqu'un avec toi tu
entends gloubiboulga et ben tu te
trompes
j'ai gagné trois fois activement dans
trois fois le concours du plus gros
mangeur de show compte oui bien alors
les autres avaient déjà mangé un soutien
alors il n'aimait pas la soupe notation
au carré
le portugal du trader je vous en prie
chacun prie ton qu'il mange plus que
l'autre eh bien nous allons organiser un
grand concours de choucroute
[Musique]
bon pour sa stalle bien ça va gagner
c'est un facteur et serviettes souhaite
faire ça c'est bien
agoride oui alors six nations a non
seulement françois à julie est ce que tu
pourrais m'apporter un peu de sauce
tomate la sauce tomate de sites dans de
la sauce tomate dans la choucroute
voilà c'était tout temps sans merci roue
ses bouquets ça met de la couleur
wallah casimir qui désirent
ça y est on peut y aller bref bon alors
atteint sur nathan ouais non non on ne
peut pas manger de la choucroute à la
sauce tomate sans fruits confits jamais
vu quelqu'un manger un plat aussi
l'écran comme ça voilà les fruits
confits on ça va être excellent je
préfère le porteur du mois de crise
voilà beau et bien casimir je pense que
comme ça on va pouvoir y aller la
tension monte
attention vous êtes prêts c'est pas tout
c'est pas possible
julie il me faudra aussi le yaourt le
tuc rendu dans la choucroute et puis les
anchois
c'est un choix les câpres
les caps la confiture de procès il a
oublié
voilà les jolies petites ans soit deux
mois la groseille tu me mets que me
mêler car s'il te plaît voilà elle a
besoin d'attention ou là ne vais pas
trop qu'on dise ici c'est bien voilà bon
alors casimir comme ça je pense que ça
suffit on va peut-être pouvoir y aller
non non ça va quasi mais maintenant tu
as tout
non non il aurait et entamerait sa
bouche je crois qu'ils élèvent à nourrir